hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 12 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet we're going to explain a couple
characters Mr Freeze is finally here I'm
so excited
hands down this episode probably my
favorite episode of the season so far it
feels like a whole different show than
it's been before
like the Gotham show that we wanted it
to be because they're doing a big
villain they have this amazing mr.
freeze character that they're setting up
and the actor did a great performance we
got to talk a lot about him in they have
freaking BD Wong playing Hugo Strange
amazing actor playing crazy character
I'm so excited so let's do top 10 WTF
and then I'll explain mr. freeze and
Hugo Strange as origin story in the
comics there are a couple other big
villains they'll have this season but it
seems like the way the episode treated
them Hugo Strange is kind of like the
big bad mr. freeze will also be one of
the biggest antagonists but not
necessarily the biggest villain but the
funny thing is is if you were to talk to
BD Wong about Hugo Strange he wouldn't
tell you that Hugo Strange as a villain
he has this grand plan he's only trying
to do good things with this Indian Hills
facility experimenting on people
none of the best villains think of
themselves as villains everybody is the
hero of their own story so here we go
top 10 WTF number 10 recap from last
season films are getting strange in this
town and the heroes are getting even
weirder to Gordon's gonna be a dad we
can address that later because that
seems like they're cooking a little
Batgirl in there unless they end up
killing the baby which I don't think
they sure would ever do but we'll just
draw like a big question mark on Morena
Baccarin stomach what is gonna crawl out
is gonna be the Barbara Gordon Batgirl
or is it going to be a character that's
original to the show fun Easter Egg
Morena Baccarin pregnant in real life
with the child of co-star Ben McKenzie
so on the show and in real life these
two people are having a baby together
surprise baby so I'm guessing that the
Leslie pregnancy was planned after
Morena Baccarin found out she was
pregnant in real life so she's like I'm
gonna be huge how are we gonna deal with
this on the show well why don't Leslie
and Gordon have a baby together
sometimes TV shows do babies because
it's part of the story sometimes they do
it to address actresses getting pregnant
in real life like if you have an actress
who's a main character on a TV show she
just can't go away for six months to
have the baby like you have to address
it somehow on the TV show but number
nine WTF meet Mr Freeze and his creepy
van excuse me sir can you open the back
of that
yeah sure sure here you go what do you
know that just happens to be a body in
there why don't you take a look at my
custom Super Soaker this is a real WTF
because Mr Freeze seems like he doesn't
know what's going on he's just kind of
reacting to each situation some of my
favorite comedies go down that way where
you have a group of terrible people like
like the hangover for instance where
each circumstance just gets worse and
works for them they make decisions
they're like oh my god what do we do
they make a decision it gets even worse
and it just spirals out of control and
that's kind of what's going on for mr.
freeze in this episode he's trying to
save his wife he needs medicine he needs
test subjects so that he can learn how
to unfreeze his wife and things just
spiral out of control go down the
[ __ ] till he has to turn himself in
at the end although you know he
technically he ends up walking away so
we're kind of witnessing the birth of
mr. freeze in this episode it's gonna be
a slow burn and on the number 8 WTF the
penguin gets sent to Arkham this is
gonna be so fun I was hoping they'd do
more Arkham Hugo Strange is a big part
of Arkham so it seems like they were
just waiting for that character to come
along like they hadn't cast him yet so
they were holding off on a lot of their
Arkham story so expect a lot more see no
evil do no evil speaking which number 7
WTF Hugo Strange experimenting on the
Arkham inmates
why is he experimenting on them we'll
find out on the TV show in the comics
he's really just cured like as a
scientist and a researcher he's just
really curious and has very questionable
morality so he has no problems using
human test subjects the same way Mr
Freeze has no problem using human test
subjects the difference between the two
of them is that it seems like Hugo
Strange research comes more from
professional curiosity than a ticking
clock to try and save someone he loves
like Mr Freeze has to get his experiment
right or his wife will die Hugo Strange
just seems like he has a fascination
with the human mind and controlling
people speaking which number 6 WTF
people that Hugo Strange is
experimenting on they drop arsonists
they're talking about firefly remember
they wheeled her in during the
mid-season finale mistakenly thinking
that she had superpowers they thought
she was invulnerable to fire they didn't
know about the jacket that she was
wearing I don't know if they're gonna
call the superpower people metahumans or
if they're gonna call them mutants or so
you're just gonna call them enhance
people whatever term you want to use is
totally fine just because this exists in
the DC Universe
and the TV shows seem to be going with
metahumans I'm gonna think of them as
metahumans so for now Indian Hills which
is connected to Arkham
is going to be the place that they
surface new metahumans from like poison
ivy we've seen poison ivy but she hasn't
got her powers yet I would be totally
cool if they want to change Cannon and
give her her powers that way because
she's a child but I think part of the
idea was some of the Batman villains is
that they age with Batman so until he
puts the cowl on we're not gonna see a
lot of the other younger characters like
poison ivy Catwoman put their costumes
on - speaking of Batman villains number
five the penguin what is going to happen
to him now that he's at the mercy of
Hugo Strange
I love how hypnotic beady Wong's
performance was Hugo Strange is meant to
have this hypnotic voice he hypnotizes
people so of course it makes sense
there's this great episode of the
animated series I can't remember the
name of it where Bruce Wayne goes to
Hugo Strange for psychoanalysis and
during the process Hugo Strange learns
that Bruce Wayne is Batman Batman is
able to discredit him so that when Hugo
Strange tells all the other big Batman
villains that Batman is Bruce Wayne they
all just laugh at him that's the most
ridiculous thing ever hands down
favorite Hugo Strange line at least
respected to the penguin was when he was
going down the elevator at the end of
the episode talking to his recorder
about how penguin had an unusual
relationship with his mother most of the
time comic book villains and heroes for
that matter all have textbook daddy
issues but every once in a while it's
mommy issues I guess you could say Bruce
Wayne has both the closest character to
actual comic book villainy in the
episode is probably you know number
three WTF Butch and Tabitha are forming
an unholy alliance
I love how cheeseball they got with it -
like when one of the villains looks up
in the sky and starts cackling with like
this amazing villain laughs that's
what's going on with Butch's character
right now so if it seemed a little silly
like a little funny that's because it's
supposed to be you're meant to laugh at
this it's supposed to be that special
blend of Batman villain comedy the butch
character is at his best when he gets to
be ridiculous like this just like
Bullock is at his best when he gets to
have his funny moments like when he and
Gordon are talking about Mr Freeze how
do you pronounce that name fries fries
I'm great with names
speaking of which number two WTF
downstairs in mr. Freeze's creepy
basement with melting test subjects I
love that visual effects scene where
he's like oh my god I've got it I
figured it out I could finally unfreeze
my wife and then the body just melts
like ice cream it's like that special
kind of Walking Dead awesome where you
kind of want to throw
up and cheer at the same time and
finally number one WTF Mr Freeze
resolves himself leaves the police
station he's gonna save his wife I will
argue that he is the biggest hero on the
show at least of this episode now when
you think heroes and villains you think
people that do bad things people that do
good things but you really shouldn't
think of it in such a diametric way
traditional heroes are measured by the
epicness of their deeds and the most
epic person in this episode was mr.
freeze so if you're just going by that
scale regardless of the bad things that
he does he's more of a hero than Gordon
is it's just that when you call someone
a hero or a villain it depends on whose
perspective you're taking from Gordon's
perspective mr. Freeze's the villain
from mr. Freeze's perspective everyone
that's trying to stop him from saving
his wife as the villain so let me know
in the comments what was your favorite
part of the episode and who do you think
is gonna be more fun this season mr.
freeze or Hugo Strange I feel like the
show is so much better right now
seriously if you have friends that
stopped watching the show because they
thought it got lame tell them to start
watching again it's a whole different
show now so let's talk comic book
characters though I know Mr Freeze seems
like the more classic Batman villain but
Hugo Strange actually debuted in the
comics before mr. freeze strange started
in Detective Comics number 36 in 1940
that is a deep cut probably the best
Hugo Strange story you need to read
though is called strange apparitions
from the 70s in like a lot of 70s comics
it gets really weird it's all about him
running this private hospital for
wealthy people keeping them trapped and
turning them into monsters which is kind
of what he's doing with Indian Hills now
so you get the idea but for the most
part the way the episode presents him is
pretty comic-book accurate he's always a
psychiatrist of some sort sometimes he
works for the police department
sometimes he works inside Arkham it just
depends on which era of the comics
you're reading the one constant is that
he is always a villain mr. freeze though
my other favorite thing from the episode
in one of my favorite Batman villains he
started in Batman 121 in 1959 but when
he first debuted in the comics his name
was mr. zero as in mr. sub-zero when the
Adam West Batman series came along in
the 60s they renamed the character mr.
freeze and henceforth he was mr. freeze
now you may notice on the TV show that
he's not frozen himself in pre-crisis
continuity they explained it as his gun
backfiring and that
what made it so that he had to keep
himself cryogenically frozen at all
times to survive post-crisis they just
deepened his backstory a little they
just said that as a child he had a
fascination with freezing animals went
to a special boarding school met his
wife Nora they eventually got married
she contracted a fatal disease so he
froze her and then tried to find a way
to heal her the new 52 origin story is
also a little bit different so for the
most part any heir of the comics you
read mr. freeze is in love with Nora in
in some form or another and is trying to
fix her but he has to commit crimes to
fund his research therefore he is a
Batman villain my great dream now is
that they can find a way via the
multiverse to connect Gotham to the
flash and arrow and we can get a captain
cold weather wizard mr. freeze team-up
in related Batman news they actually
drops a new Batman V Superman footage
last night I think there's gonna be some
special stuff later this week but since
always some of the new footage is new
what I'm gonna do is just stitch all the
clips together so that it's all the new
stuff and I'll do video for that next so
be sure to subscribe to get that and
then I'll be doing a new flash bonus
video for the flash season 2 later
tonight so new Batman V Superman new
flash stuff coming today while you guys
wait for that stuff to post you can
click here for this special game of
thrones season six behind the six video
it's really cool and you can click here
for my Deadpool Iron Man video thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you